hello everyone welcome back to PJ's cake
class the same authorized Rhino trainer
I'd like to do everything in Rhino 3d
software that possible enjoyed industry
you have Rhino plug-in professional
software like jim vision metric and
renault girl people often ask me why
don't you just use them instead of
building everything from scratch in
right on 3d they are two reason for it I
personally use Rhino goal for my jury
design since there are a lot of little
features for quick stone selling model
but for many start-up designer both
program may be a big investment to start
with second if you know how to build a
model from scratch you don't have to
limit yourself design from the library
those two professional jewelry program
has so long story short learn the
fundamental model concept may take
longer time on your Learning Path but
you will be benefit to you in the long
run for your CAD design a career what
I'd like to show you today is build this
engagement ring is really popular form
in lot of a commercial jewelry and then
we're gonna build a six prong hat and
building this little bridging in the
middle and also build the ring shank
with a open on the top and finally we're
gonna edit this little besetting diamond
all the way around on both sides the
video might take too long to finish for
just one so I would like to separate
this video in two part just in case
you're wondering what kind of display
view I'm using if you go into this
little triangle right here and you will
see artistic and this is the view I'm
using I usually use the coast view are
you ready let's get started
let's start with this five millimeter
rhinestone and then for how to make this
stone you can go on the right top corner
there and then you will see the info
there will be a link for my previous
video all right so we want to do a six
prong on it first of all we want to
decide what type of prong size you can
do the wrong one but the one that I have
is more of the cushion looking so I want
to decided the the prong I want to
snapping into the grid so I turn down
the great snap on the bottom and then
let's do from the center right there you
can decide whatever size you want it
that since I'm planning to have a six
prong and this is it's not super big of
the storm so I wanted to do is more like
a one-minute either so I'm going to type
a 1 here and also type in one now you
can choose to have the corner you have
to choice here right here you have a
corner its arc oh there's another very
interest one it's called conic and what
it does is give you a little bit more of
the cushion let's go to conic and they
give you a little bit more of a cushion
looking and I really like this shape
right there
alright so we have the prong right there
now the prong is going to over the
girdle ideally you don't want it to be
too short but you don't want to be too
long they are actually two type of a
model for rendering purpose and for CAD
which you are going to casting purpose
for the casting purpose you want to
leave it a little bit longer so your
jeweler will have some room to bend the
middle over okay so let me move this in
a little bit you can moving 30 percent
40 percent or even more like 50 percent
of entire area but definitely not over
50% because you're gonna make your prong
really weak I usually do in between 30
to 40 okay so that's the profile full of
fun I prom and then I need to know what
is the shape going to the palette you
want them to have the same I'm going to
use the combo drag it and tap my Aki so
then you will have a copy there and I'm
going to flip it 90 degree right there
okay so you don't want it to matter to
touch the qulet which is this point part
of the stone and then only close to the
middle as possible okay now we wanted to
have a shape of profile for the shape
and depends on how you like it there are
a couple way to do it you can just go
ahead to you know draw the shape that
you like it something like this from
quarter court so at the perspective you
can see they are like it or you can do
is put two little tab so once here and
once here and then you can use the blend
tool blend curve which is right here
and then you blend from here to here so
I kind of giving you different kind of
profile and you can adjust it okay that
way is when you have the prong on the
other side it will blend better let's
click OK
all right so now you can delete those
two tabs let's take a look on the
perspective view so we have this we can
do is using the sweep one rail and this
is the rail cross cross section and then
you hit enter then you will get that
prompt there so next step we need to
make sure it is solid so we want to do
is type a cab CA P then I will have a
cab now it doesn't look too nice full of
rendering if you have really sharp edges
so let's go ahead to fit it the edges so
let's go to fit it and then radius let's
type it point to maybe let's give it a
try
all right so it looked nice over there
all right I'd like to do six prong few
things to way you can do it you can use
the polar array which might be faster or
you can use rotate with the copy so
let's try the polar array it's living
under the transform and you have array
you have taller okay so I want to type
it Center is a zero and one six of them
and 360 degree so I will have this prong
set all right if you like everything
everything look nice to you just go
ahead and bowling all of them at once
all right so now we have our head it's
done
I also depends on the orientation that
you have in this case I would like to
have a rotating 90 degree I'm sorry it's
30 degree and then so that way it will
have two prong touching the shank which
is more stable than one prong is
touching okay alright so now that's
starting working on the ring shank
I'm going to draw a circle and like most
of my demonstration the diameter is
going to be 16 all right and then I'm
going to move this one above the circle
and that's where the prong is going to
be now let's take a look on the
perspective all right this is what we
have there the next step what we're
going to do is create a shank on the
original one you can see I have this
open on the top and what I did is
actually I need to draw the curve first
I'm going to create another layer so
it's not blocking and I'm going to call
the first layer as hat
the second layer I'm going to call a
ring shank all right so I'm gonna send
this circle to the ring shank you're not
gonna turn the Hat all so he's easier
for let's take a look alright so the
first things I would like to do is
creating the arc right and they can be
anywhere but make sure that you want it
to almost touching the center okay I'm
holding the shift' so I can get the half
circle that's the arc right the second
things I'm going to do is I'm gonna put
another little tab here
all right so instead of drawing the
curve and this might be too fat instead
I'll join a curve I'm going to use the
blend tool so we're gonna use the blend
is living on their icon here and then
you're gonna plan from here to here all
right so you may have something that I
have here now let's take a look on the
perspective that's because the original
two tab they are not on the same place
right to fix this problem you just need
to pick up the curve you want them to be
flat to the sea plane and you type a
project to see plane we want to delete
the original one yes and then now if you
look at a perspective there are polls on
the sea plane okay so let's do we again
using the point tool I'm gonna plan from
here to here and it looks alright to me
let's click OK alright so I have that
one and since it's gonna be symmetrical
so I just need to copy to the other side
and kind of joining it alright so the
question is how am I gonna get this
curve follow the ring shank the command
we are going to use is called a curve
from to view its living under the curve
come in and then you pick up this curve
and this curve and very quickly you see
this curve they're gonna turn this in
the red colors and easier for you to see
okay once we have as things we only need
the top part we don't need a bottom part
so I'm gonna use this curve to trim the
bottom part so now I have this one on
the top okay
since it's gonna be symmetrical you can
mirror to the other side but I don't
want to me or everything to the other
side I want to finish one side and then
mural to the other side okay now let's
take a look on this top view now we need
to make it into the solid right so we
need to create some sort of profile
that's starting creating the profile to
make it solid I'm going to use the
rectangular tool and then choose the
center so I'm snapping into the quadrant
right there I'm going to use the one
point two millimeters stone so since you
are bigger than one-point-two and
leaving some room for the the prong that
you will be fine you don't want it to be
too thick but you don't want to be too
thin either I'm going to have it as
about over 1.5 millimeters thick and
roughly about one point eight millimeter
and I'm using the corner for conic so
you can have this cushion looking
surface I'm sorry cushion looking corner
so that's moving this from the midpoint
to the closet so you're not cutting
inside of a ring size all right now I
need to move this in a little bit to the
center line so I can make sure that I
can overlapping them and I'm gonna use
the mirror to mirror to the other side
all right so let's take a look on the
perspective all right this will be the
profile folder sweep one let's do sweep
one this is the rail you go from here to
here and then you got this surface there
it looks alright let's take a look on
the top it doesn't over the middle take
a look on the stone it's kind of cut
into the prong maybe too much because I
do need to have a stone over there so
let's do a little bit of justment let's
delete this one and we want to delete
the red one because you have so many
control point it's hard for you to do
the Edit by just dragging the control
point so we want to edit the original
one so let's pick up all the point that
you're going to move and let's drag it
back a little bit you don't have to drag
it way too much we just need it to be
shorter so there will be a gap there
let's take a look on the curve when you
have curve from a to view this curve in
that curve okay it looked like it has a
good you know shape but let's take a
look first sweep one cross-section and
look like it's alright
okay so now we have this one and again
just not confusing I'm going to this
original one to trim up the bottom curve
alright so now that one look okay is
touching the the the center stone let's
take a look how do we create a bottom
one I'm going to have this curve and
going to copy that curve snapping into
the quadrant to the quadrant of my ring
shank alright and out from the you you
have that little profile right there and
we are going to use the rotate tool to
rotate it 90 degree alright then let me
go back to the perspective and that's
height that one
so we need to have those two profiles
sweep to the button so you won't be have
a very nice plan and so we need to make
that two into one let's go ahead and
trim off those two and while they are
select let's join them and don't forget
to mirror that to the other side
all right now it's time to do the sweep
again let's go to sweep one and you will
go from here to here to here usually I
like it to align to the center of or
inside of the ring shank center of Exile
ring shank and make sure that they are
pointing the same direction so I'm gonna
go this one for in the same direction
and let's take a look all right
blend it really well it's tapered down
to the botton and let's turn on the par
we just did all right
it looked really nice as well let's go
ahead to mirror that surface to the
other side of the Ring and that's
joining together so now you become solid
all we need to do now is fill a little
breach there so it's more comfortable on
the finger so I'm gonna use the bottom
profile again on my top view our front
view and then I'm going to rotate it to
somewhere inside of that shape okay I'm
going to turn into the red color it's
easier for you to see let's take a look
on the perspective
now you see the profile right there and
we can create a bridge but I do not want
a bridge is too fat so I actually want
to scale one D tau so let's go to scale
tool use scale one D snapping into the
quadrant to the corner and it's kind of
bring it down so make sure the bottom is
still stay I'll be ring shank let's go
ahead to me roll this guy to the other
side okay
so all we need to do again it's going to
be sweep one this is my rail and I'm
going to sweep from this curve to this
curve okay so now we have something on
the button for our C hat to sit on so
that way you don't have to be realized
on the head to holding the shank and
don't forget to cap this one because
that's only a surface open surface and
for aesthetic purpose our money to move
ahead just a little bit up all right so
I have definitely enough room for my
stone to run through all right
so that's the basic of ring shank that
we have wait a minute I see this a
surface in between and it is okay for
the rendering but not too okay when you
wanted to print it it's all right so
that's fixed let me turn the head off
all right so I don't know if you see
what I see there but it's it's
overlapping surface so we need to trim
that if you want to let's export it so
back to this part and separately all the
bottom we can join back together they
don't have problem okay
so I'm going to hide this one so see you
probably will see better what I mean
there because we overlapping
the the profile a little bit so you got
double surface there right if you say
I'm going to trim this guy I see you're
gonna trim it doesn't let you trim right
so it doesn't work so the way to do this
you have to split your model first let's
take on the look on the top view and
that's draw a curve like the cross our
model on the top view I'm going to use
the this curve to split the dam into
four different pieces so that's use the
split those two will be split by this
curve so now you have multiple pieces
right and we no longer need those small
ones so we can just go ahead and delete
that small one oops this one and also we
can did it all we need to do now is join
those pieces back together all right
and then let's take a look on the bottom
just turn you back to the bottom and
let's join those together all right now
in our properties say right here is a
closed solid polished surface so which
is good with this one and this one
that's also bowling it together and then
double check again
it's closed solid poly surface all right
so let's go back and turn on the head
there all right I don't want to join a
head yet because I might need to have a
completely surface to do my stone next
all right so this is the basic shape of
this ring so next step we are going to
do the besetting on the ring shank all
the way around so stay tuned
it will coming up for the following
Monday I hope you enjoy the video please
like and comment
and share my video it takes really long
time roughly about five hour to make a
15 minutes video so your help on sharing
and also comment it's helping me ranking
on YouTube thank you for watching see
you next Monday
[Music]